E
NATION."
BRIAN: TIKTOK THE MOST POPULAR
APP IN THE WORLD WITH ONE
BILLION USERS, BOTH DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS ARE USING IT AS
A CAMPAIGN TOOL.
EVEN AFTER FINDING OUT THE APP
SHARES USER DATA WITH CHINA.
TRUMP WANTED TO GET RID OF IT.
NEIL FERGUSON JOINS US NOW.
SHOULD BOTH PARTIES BE USING
TIKTOK?
>> WHEN I FIRST LOOKED AT TIKTOK
A COUPLE YEARS AGO, I COULDN'T
BELIEVE MY EYES.
IT WAS DANCING FERRETS AND
PEOPLE BEHAVING IDIOTICALLY IN
THEIR KITCHENS AND GYMS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK CLOSELY, TWO
THINGS STRIKE YOU.
THIS IS A HUGELY POPULAR APP
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE.
MILLIONS AND TENS OF MILLIONS OF
YOUNG AMERICANS USE IT.
THEY PREFER IT TO FACEBOOK.
IT'S ALL THE RAGE.
SECONDLY IT'S A CHINESE OWNED
APP.
ALL YOUR DATA, AND IT'S ALL
ABOUT DATA, ARE ACCESSIBLE BY
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
YOU MIGHT THINK WHO CARES ABOUT
MY PREFERENCES FOR DANCING
FERRETS.
BUT ANYBODY USING TIKTOK IS
GENERATING QUITE A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
PREFERENCES.
WHILE IT MAY SEEM THEIR
PREFERENCES ARE INANE THINGS,
THAT INFORMATION CAN BE
ENORMOUSLY USEFUL IF IT'S
AVAILABLE IN LARGE SCALE.
BRIAN: THEY WILL TRY TO MAKE IT
COOL TO BE CHINA.
SPEAK OF RUSSIA AND THE COLD
WAR.
IT'S AMAZING WHAT'S TAKEN PLACE
THE LAST FEW WEEKS AS UKRAINE
GOT ON THE OFFENSIVE.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" GOT AHOLD
OF INTEREST CREPTS USING THEIR
CELL PHONES AND CALLING BACK TO
OTHER PEOPLE AND SHARING THAT
CELL PHONE.
ONE WAS, ONE SOLDIER CALLING
HOME.
NO ONE TOLD US THEY WERE GOING
TO WAR.
THEY WARNED US ONE DAY BEFORE WE
LEFT.
ANOTHER INTEREST CREPT.
PUTIN IS A FOOL.
HE WANTS TO TAKE KYIV, BUT THERE
IS NO WAY WE CAN DO IT.
WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN
THE BATTLEFIELD?
>> THEIR MORALE IS ROCK BOTTOM.
I ESTIMATE SOMETHING LIKE A
QUARTER OF THE INITIAL INVASION
FORCE IS DEAD BECAUSE THEY
WILDLY UNDERESTIMATED UKRAINE'S
ABILITY AND UKRAINE ARMED WITH
WESTERN WEAPONS HAS PROVEN TO BE
A FORMIDABLE FOE.
THE SAME WEEK PRESIDENT PUTIN IS
ANNEXING CHUNKS OF UKRAINE, THE
WESTERN FORCES ARE LOSING THEIR
GRIP ON IT.
MAKING THE PERFORMANCE IN MOSCOW
YESTERDAY YESTERDAY A COMPLETE
SHAM AND A FARCE.
THERE IS A CHANCE UKRAINE CAN
TAKE SOME LANDS BACK.
THAT'S WHY PUTIN IS THREATENING
TO USING A PEEK INTO CARE THE
U.S. AND UKRAINIAN.
BRIAN: WHO DO YOU THINK BLEW UP
THE PIPELINE?
>> RUSSIA.
IT'S PART OF THE MADMAN THEORY.
YOU WANT TO INTIMIDATE YOUR
ENEMIES TO MAKE THEM THINK YOU
ARE MAD.
ATTEMPTING TO USE A NUCLEAR
WEAPON AND BLOWING UP PIPELINES.
ALL OF THIS I THINK IS DESIGNED
TO CAUSE US TO SLOW DOWN THE
WEAPONS DELIVERIES INSTEAD DOING
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING AND
STEPPING THEM UP TO PRESS OUR
ADVANTAGE.
BRIAN: WE HA